[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host chris hogan
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we talk to you about your life
and your money the phone number to do
that is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five julie and dallas is
gonna start this hour off hi julie how
are you
hi how are you great how can we help
uh well thank you for taking my call um
i just wanted to ask you
about paying off debt before investing
into retirement while being exempt from
social security tax
um can i give you a few facts and
figures first sure
okay so i'm a stay-at-home mom my
husband's a youth minister with a salary
of forty thousand eight hundred
uh that increases by two percent each
year and because he's a minister
um we accepted the option of being
exempt from paying into social security
and instead invest on our own for
retirement
because we live rent free it's part of
the package we have a personal tone
um that value of the home 14 400 it
has to be added into our income correct
uh when we calculate the 15
self-employment tax um so our combined
debt
is a little over 123 000. why would you
be paying self-employment
well the 15.3 that would be going to
social security
we don't have to pay self-employment tax
i know you don't um that's just the
church
um gives us half of that
and we can invest that on our own
insurance give you half of it you can do
whatever you want to do with it yeah
right right so okay so there's not a
self-employment today
we're not sure what to do yet yeah okay
you just haven't you have the seven and
a half or seven six five
as income from the church additionally
uh
right because you opted out of social
security okay i'm in
yeah okay that doesn't mean you have to
send it there
no no we don't we've been saving what
they give us and our house
um until we figure out what to do with
it so
our combined debt is a little over 123
000
about 13 000 of that is a car loan and
the rest is student loans
goodness um yes expensive seminary
degree
yes yeah um
so our loans are on income-based payment
right now so all we're required to pay
even though we do
um try and pay more sometimes is 127
dollars a month
so obviously not very much um and you
don't work
no i don't why
hello i think we lost her well she
didn't like that question
might have been yeah might have been a
glitch might have been a glitch in the
system i don't know but but i mean in
looking at this dave i mean
forty thousand dollar income let's go
ahead and answer her question yeah okay
forty thousand dollar income
um with the housing allowance but
they're staring at thirteen thousand in
a car loan
and a hundred and ten thousand in
student loan debt right you know that
it's not time to be investing no it's
time to start chopping
yeah and i'm i'm thinking i'd think the
path you were going and i was going to
say it
she needs to get plugged into some type
of job or side gig
to help chop this dead down he does too
yeah yeah
they're going to pick up extra income
because the problem is a shovel hole
ratio that's what you're saying
that's right how much hole they're in
there's a hundred and something thousand
dollars versus a forty thousand dollar
income
so i gotta i gotta get the income up so
that the debt is not
a death sentence that's right it doesn't
ride you all the way into the grave
right and you've got to be able to
attack it and so if you got your income
up 20 grand you'd be done in five years
yeah if you put all that on the on there
and if you got your income up
more you might be out faster so i i
think you should be out of debt in three
to five years
a hundred percent debt free and uh then
and only then would you build your
emergency fund baby step three and then
you do your
then you start saving fifteen percent
right is it wise for pastors to do this
yes yes uh it's a conscientious
objection
the irs form says i have to object to
the
if you're a pastor your pastoral income
only not your side gig income
but only your pastoral income
ministerial income if you
conscientiously object to
on a religious basis the social security
system
then you cannot pay into it and not
receive from it
now what does social security do for us
well it's a horrible savings
plan absolutely horrendous has a
negative rate of return right
you don't even get back what you put
into it that's right so from an
investment standpoint you could invest
in a fruit jar
and come off better okay but you need to
do some investing so
which is her fear right but we're still
going to work the baby steps so they got
plenty of time to get to investing
and it also covers disability in the
event you become disabled you get ssi
and in the event of the death of one of
the
parents the child children you receive
it would get benefits
and none of that occurs if you opt out
now uh then the question has always come
up for our friends in the christian
community uh because since we're
believers and we're always in that
community they're always asking well
should we opt out um i said yes
mathematically financially as long as
you're going to buy disability insurance
life insurance
and do your retirement you're going to
come out much better out
of millions of dollars better off right
i wish i could opt out
right uh matter of fact they could keep
everything i paid in so far if they just
wouldn't take anymore
that's how bad it is you know it's just
bad it is bad math and so oh it's awful
so
if you had worked let's see dmv managing
your retirement plan that's what social
security is
if he had worked a job for four or five
years paid into social security then
became a pastor
and he opts out he would get social
security based on what he paid in
okay all right yeah but but not and if
you work a side hustle
you're still not ministerial you opt out
except on the religious
income okay ministerial income okay and
i and i advise pastors to opt out as
long as they're gonna do those three
things that's a long-term disability
life insurance and safety for retirement
which by the way we're teaching them to
do anyway that's right
that's right this light year's better
off now can i
in good conscience be a conscientious
objector
uh on a religious basis if i'm in their
shoes
in an instant because the bible says
to be a good manager to be a good
steward
to manage the assets that god has
allowed you to manage well
sending any of it to the government to
mismanage
does not qualify as being a good manager
you're right so
on a religious basis i instantaneously
can object to it
okay uh now i don't get to because i
don't have a ministerial income
right but uh but if you're a pastor out
there that's the basis for it and
and you have to do it right at the start
of your uh pastoral
career career okay and so it's one page
it's a one-page thing
and uh it's you know you're from a
matter of integrity you are signing up
not because you don't like the math
but you're signing up to say well on a
religious basis i object
okay and i can do that i can show you
how i mean i i
as a christian i object right but i
don't get to you don't get top down
okay that's interesting and you don't
either by the way right right
mar is with us mars in cleveland ohio
we're going to come back tomorrow after
the break
because uh we discussed that whole
concept all the way into the break which
is perfect because
hey people wonder what this is oh yeah
yeah
and your parsonage is taxable income
so that's why they're allocating a
portion of it to that so
still got to work the steps though still
got to work the plan you're going to get
out of it what you put into it
only way it works this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
[Music]
chministries.org
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the dave ramsey show
common sense to your doc for your
dollars and since chris hogan ramsey
personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five chris hogan show is
available on youtube apple
google podcast siriusxm it's a podcast
it's a youtube show it's everywhere
and you can always listen to chris and
um
focus not finished baby that's just
saying over there so uh be sure you jump
in and check that out
phone number again here triple eight
eight two five five two two five as
promised mar
is in cleveland ohio hey mar how are you
hi jane hi chris how you doing great man
what's up
hey so um my wife and i are on baby step
2
we have 15 000 left on our car so my
question is
after we get our emergency fund done our
crush was paid off this year
after we get our emergency fund done so
we
continue to pause on our baby steps and
um not start my son's college fund and
to scale up our house we owe a hundred
and ten thousand
um last year i made over uh ninety
thousand
gross income fifty eight thousand was
brought home
so i was thinking if i pay we were to
pay
two two grand a month uh extra to our
principal
which would be 24 000 a year
uh our house can be paid off in three
and a half years yeah
uh what do you guys think about that
well you when you
finish baby step three and you've got
your emergency fund in place and you're
debt free
then you move on to four five and six
that's right and they're simultaneous
that's exactly right and so mark you
will have up to then done things one at
a time
but getting to that fully funded
emergency fund doing four five and six
you're going to be investing 15 percent
saving time for college and paying extra
to the house
so if that means it's two instead of
2000 if that means it's 1700
that's okay then that's fine yeah but
here's what you're not counting mar
your income should be increasing
so that in itself should give you the
opportunity to pay off that house faster
buddy
uh how old are you i'm 31 and my wife is
29.
and how old are your kids uh my son we
only have one and he's three years old
okay you sound focused man um and i'm
gonna tell you this
you will find the extra money to pay off
that house
i have no doubt in my mind but at the
same time you're making
progress in these other areas so don't
don't don't
not don't avoid doing one thing so you
can focus all in another
make progress in it all so i'm okay baby
step five
save for kids college we're okay if
you're doing anything
there i just want you to start building
that muscle if you just set up an
account to do 100 bucks a month 50 bucks
a month whatever it doesn't have to be a
lot
but let's get started on it to kind of
get the rhythm in your brain and in your
household and your spirit
that we're saving for college we're
saving for college we're saving for
college and then we're just everything
else we're gonna start dumping on six
we're gonna get the house paid off as
quickly as we can
now you said you brought home 58 out of
90.
where's all that money going that's
you're not taxes
i brought her 68. oh 68. okay that's
much better that's much closer all right
good well you're doing i agree with
chris i think you're doing great i do
too
i really do and i think you know being
laser focused on that
but dave people oftentimes don't account
for either income increasing or finding
other ways to
bring in extra money you can still make
progress well what ends up happening
for real is you do get raises
periodically you get bonuses
and then other money is just found money
comes across our our life it always does
in our lives i mean
you might get a little small inheritance
a little five thousand dollar
inheritance or something you might get a
uh
a twenty thousand dollar or something uh
you may find something you may find a
gold rock in your backyard and sell it i
don't know i mean there's
little stuff happens and as long as all
the little stuff
above 15 going to retirement above
whatever you're doing for colleges all
going on six
then you accelerate the process and i
would rather you do
four and five and paying off your home
take
four years or four and a half years
instead of three and a half years and
not be doing any four and five gotcha
yeah yeah yeah and that that's that's
the clarification he's looking for good
job man well done stella
is in dallas hey stella how are you
just fine thank you thanks for uh um
taking my call today sure what's up
i'm on baby step baby step number seven
i'm single
45 years old i maximize my 401k and roth
ira
contributions annually great um
when should i make a conversion from my
401k
or to raw 41k how old are you
focus on my savings 47 i'm 45
now yes sir
now when you when you uh when you fl how
much is in your 401k today
uh about 840 000. oh
way to go millionaire stella
stella's on the ball all right now wait
a minute i got to back up then because
you're going to create taxes on whatever
you roll right
do you have other cases do you have
other i know but do you have other cash
i do how much i have about a hundred
thousand on my
um savings account okay
so i don't want to flip it all and you
have to use
some of that money cashing it out early
to pay taxes
and that's what would happen because
you're gonna have a couple hundred
thousand in taxes
so i'm gonna move i'm gonna move as much
as i can pay the taxes without touching
it
so let's call that 400 grand and you use
the hundred grand to pay your taxes or
whatever it works out right
something like that tax bracket is about
32 this
last year okay then then you can back
into it and say
based on that i've got and you got 100
but you have an emergency fund in
addition to that hundred
no okay so i have some non-retirement
investment accounts that i could
liquidate oh how much is that uh
about eight hundred thousand okay then
let's do it all now
and let's use some of your cash and some
of your non-retirement investments to
pay the taxes
because effectively what that does
mathematically
is that is as if you have just invested
another 250
000 into your roth ira yep because the
roth's going to grow 100 tax-free from
here on out
see so you freed all of that up now i'm
assuming since you're such a freaking
rock star here that
that this money is invested in good
mutual funds and you're getting good
rates of return right
yes sir you are you're killing us what
do you
make
thank you how much do you make oh i'm
sorry uh about 200 000
how did you learn how to do all this you
are really good
i am i'm focused but not finished
stella you just making me feel good
today i'm telling you he just turned
into one big gooseberry seriously i
really did
i i i no but seriously where did you
learn did you did your parents teach you
are you self-taught
um pretty much self-taught yesterday are
you really
well you have done a wonderful wonderful
job you really have 45 years old 2
million
yeah and this 100 000 you have in your
savings stella leave 30 in there is your
emergency fund
yeah uh just so you keep that cushion
but girl i'm proud of you
i'm going to tell you and you know what
that high definition dream you've been
chasing
i hope you're living i hope you're
having fun uh knowing that you're on the
path
to be a blessing to people and giving
but also living and enjoying some stuff
way to go yes well done well done
rockstar
trevor's in cleveland ohio hey trevor
how are you
good dave chris thank you guys for
taking my call sure how can we help
yeah dave i've got a business started
here and uh
my lease payment is coming up on my
truck for my landscaping business and i
was
really honestly not sure where i want to
go this summer when the leaking payment
comes up whether i want to just buy the
truck outright and keep it with my
business
or maybe try and find something else and
i'm kind of in a predicament there
um so i can see if you can kind of help
me out with that just pretend like you
didn't own it would you buy it
yes okay and would you buy it for that
price
um not knowing what the price is is kind
of well
there's a stated price on a closed end
lease at the end of the lease that you
can buy it for
right yeah i would i would probably end
up buying it but i also have the
alternative of maybe going and getting
something cheaper i know and i'm really
not sure i'm on
about baby step number three um
so what is the truck the trick is what's
the buyout number
and then look the truck up and see what
the truck is worth
don't pay more for it than it's worth
just because you're leasing it but if
you can buy two thousand dollars under
what it's worth and you can pay cash for
it then let's go ahead and buy it if it
fits in your plan
and if you want to move cheaper then
just turn it back in give them the keys
go
just don't go higher yeah there's no
reason to go up and don't do another
lease
for god's sake yeah you've earned your
way out of this thing so quit it
stop that fleeces are
fleeces are a bad idea this is the dave
ramsey chef
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five julia
is in gaithersburg maryland hi julia how
are you
hi how are you thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
so i'm an 18 year old i'm especially i'm
a first year college student
i have a 14 000 car loan i only got it
because
i needed i needed it for schools i got
it right before the pandemic hit
and for work as well um i'm able to pay
for it so
um the loan is um me and my mom
co-signed it so it's just
but i pay for it um but my question is i
just finished baby step number one which
is you know save up that one thousand
dollars
um i'm trying to get out of baby step
number two which is pay off all my debt
which as of right now
is just my car loan but my main question
is
um my mom is in a lot of debt as well
how can i help her get out of her debt
but
not only help her get out of debt but
how can i help her listen to your steps
and
um so that we can become financially
free together
you know work together well i love your
heart
i tell you i love your heart i really do
and
you know unfortunately what she's done
is she shared her taste of debt with you
and you know i'm gonna tell you you know
one of the strongest things you could do
julia
would be to get intentional and look at
getting this car sold
and get it out of your life and then you
saving up and paying cash for a car
and talking to your mom about how you
know that that's not helping
and i think you living it is one of
going to be one of the best ways
um but you know i mean you can talk with
her and you can
plant try to plant the seed but you
can't you can't make her
and dave and i have found this out after
many many years
of until someone decides they're ready
they're not ready
yeah and so yeah you living it in front
of her
and you've got the powdered butt
syndrome once someone's powdered your
butt
they don't care about what your opinion
is about
about money sex stuff like that so mom
doesn't you know
she's not gonna listen to you that much
i mean you can just the only thing you
can always do with anybody
is not to wag your finger at them and
say you know you need to listen this
podcast because you're stupid with money
because you're you you could do better
mom you could do
and don't wag your finger that way
instead just talk about yourself
because your story is not debatable you
know i feel so much better now that i'm
on a plan i got a budget i feel so much
better now that i'm getting this car
paid off or getting rid of this car
i feel so much better uh now that and
man if i could ever help you
i mean you just if you let me share with
you what i'm doing that's fine and so
um you ever had a friend uh julia lost a
bunch of weight
yeah yes they have yeah they inspire you
don't they
right without without coming over to you
and saying you know you need to do you
need to take better care of yourself
they they just they just take better
care of themselves right in front of you
yeah and then you go well how'd you do
that
that's right what'd you do you know i've
had a lot of those discussions i've lost
37 pounds since the pandemic and so
i needed to because i was just straight
up fat and so
uh but everybody's all my buddies are
like what you do
you know it's the same thing and i i
didn't go around and say you know you
need to be doing this and
didn't look at my buddy and go hey you
got one of those things hanging on the
front of you like i do
so i didn't do that i didn't didn't
shame anybody else right i just said you
know
that belly there is you know i didn't i
didn't talk about his belly i didn't i
didn't pick on him you know
but i just you know my stuff my clothes
just fit again you know
kind of stuff well and you're right dave
her doing it herself and i'm going to
tell you at 18 years old
imagine pressure for her to have the
presence of mind to reach out to call in
is a big deal i wasn't thinking like
that at 18 years old and so
you know julia live the principles young
lady
live them and be intentional for
yourself and please please please
don't take on student loan debt you said
you got that car loan i want you to sell
that get that out of your life
go to school part-time if you have to
while you work but
avoid student loan debt don't add it to
your plate yeah well done michael is
with us michael's in
alexandria virginia hey michael how are
you
good how are you doing guys uh so my
wife and i are planning on paying off
our house in about a year
great looking you know i'm looking ahead
and i'm wondering
after we do that and uh we put the 15
into retirement what i'm looking to do
is what should we do with the additional
money we'll have to invest would you
suggest
maxing out all retirement avenues
possible
prior to like a regular brokerage
what would you use a brokerage account
for
i'm thinking more of just like um
low-cost index funds that um
you know have a little more
accessibility okay i mean you can do
that
but if you get with a smart investor pro
they can help you lay that
out but yeah you max out all the
retirement all of it all of it
and then if you want to just open some
uh i do that i've got some s p
500 funds that are no loads and i store
up money in that until i get ready to
buy something else with it usually a
piece of real estate is what i'll use it
for because it's the two things i
invest in and uh but that's the beauty
of it
the other thing you'll find is if you've
got that sitting there and you said it's
accessible that's a good word liquid
then if something comes along and you
you you feel prompted by god to be
really generous to something
and and you know you may write some
sizable checks out of that investment
account
just to be a blessing at some point too
that's the other thing we have used ours
for absolutely and michael i tell you
i'm going to
uh uh to get your info i'm gonna send
you my book everyday millionaires
uh kelly will get your information and
send that to you because also in that
book i talk about
uh the bridge account and so this is
where you would start to using gross
stock mutual funds
outside of retirement to allow you to
kind of continue to save as well
yeah and you got what you're doing is
building up money that you can utilize
before
59 and a half that's exactly right
you're bridging from where you are now
until 59 and a half because you can't
touch the retirement stuff without
penalties
prior to that so that's a that's a good
suggestion kent is with us in kansas
city hey kent welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave if i could provide you with some
dollar figures could you help me
estimate the value of my small
business i'm about ready to sell i'll
give it a shot
it's a small service business i'm the
boss i'm the only employee i drive
around and
distribute printed materials like
magazines brochures and i
put on about 23 000 to 24 000
a year so gas expenses are my main
expense
the average i
started it in 2013
and so the average total amount of
income
uh about the past seven years is about
41
000 so it's a low of about 38
500 to a high of about 49
500. now that's the gross revenue that's
not before expenses that's
that is before expenses not after yeah
that's
that's the gross product revenue not not
with it now
when i figure it with the tax stuff uh
is is different from what all the
deductions and they have depreciation
and they take off for my home office use
and produce my garage as a business
purpose and stuff like that
but so then what i figure for my you
know
gas expenses and and stuff like that is
a little bit different but
do you need to have what the at total
average yeah what was your taxable
income
um that averaged
um past six seven years about eighteen
thousand yeah i was going to say 20. i
was going to be my guest okay
cool well here here's the thing some of
those
categories are what we call ghost
categories for purposes of valuation
and some of our real expenses that the
tax
uh thing is just allowing you to admit
now your home office is a ghost expense
because you're
you know you you're not really uh you
don't own
that as an office it's just you're
taking the
appreciation on that which is going to
cause a problem when you sell the house
by the way but
um anyway the uh
so some of those things are real
expenses and some of them aren't
all of them are not ghost expenses so it
sounds like you have an income
of around thirty thousand dollars uh and
so
there's two ways to look at this number
one most of the time on a service
business we say all right the
do you have a series of clients is it a
client list
yeah the the customer base uh that's
what
generates i mean that's the value that's
where the value is yeah okay
that's what i thought so i think you
could probably sell that
for about one time your uh roughly one
time if you could sell it for fifty
thousand dollars i'd take it
because generally speaking a um
you know someone else can just go
generate their own customers and that
sure that's your what you're competing
with
but generally speaking you take a the
net profit of a business
times four but that would be after you
paid all the employees and we've not
paid you out of this yet
to do the work by the time we pay you
there's not going to be money left
so i'm probably just going to try to
sell the list as a value rather than the
business
as a value
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
guys we're working on a new podcast a
special
and we're looking for some stories from
you if you've had a
bad experience with this buy now
pay later promises flexible payment
options you've probably seen these
options when you're buying something
online like a new pair of jeans
you reach the checkout page and you can
buy them for three dollars
a month that kind of stuff if you got
caught in an installment payment program
ended up costing you way more than you
expected for the item
we want to hear from you buy now pay
later
email us if you've got some stories your
story could help a lot of people
email us at dave on air at
ramseysolutions.com
put in the subject line buy now pay
later dave on air
at ramseysolutions.com buy now
pay later tell us a little bit about
your story and our team we'll get back
with you as we're producing that new
podcast
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two
five scott is in washington d.c hey
scott welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks uh thanks for having me
my wife and i are avid listeners and
thanks for your advice
thanks how can we help um yeah so we're
29
we're debt-free and done with baby step
four but no babies yet
um and no house yet either we've got a
healthy emergency fund
um over 12 months of expenses right now
we're
maxing out both of our 401ks at 19.5 a
year
but we're over the limit for roth ira
and over the tax advantage salary limit
for traditional
so i was planning on um now that we have
a you know time horizon of about three
to five years on both
kids and a house uh planning on dumping
about
two thousand per month in the mutual
fund for the next
yeah three-ish years um
do you think that's a good plan or
should i park that money elsewhere
that'd be fine i mean if you dump it
into just a no-load again like we're
talking saying a minute ago a no-load
s p 500 now you can do a back-door roth
yep i do one and my income is more you
know way over the limit
um in the back door roth my fact i just
finished mine the other day
is you open an after tax
traditional not a before tax traditional
and instantaneously roll it
to a roth and that's a loophole in the
law that allows you to do that and
regardless of your income you can do a
roth
so you can pop uh you know six thousand
bucks a piece you and your wife into
that if you want to in addition to
maxing out your 401k at the full which
you're doing
uh and then above that you're just
saving towards the house it sounds like
right right yeah and so
you're a little thick on your emergency
fund too i wouldn't be at 12 months
okay yeah so scott one option you could
do is you could take
six months of that emergency fund and
lump that over and let's call leave it
in the emergency fund but let's call
that home down payment
okay that's the starter for the starter
for that anyway and if you don't have
the money to fund those two backdoor
roth rights
use some of that yeah for that as well
right yeah just get in touch with the
smartvestor pro tell them backdoor roth
ira they can tell you how to do it
but the limits on roth ira folks are 200
000 household income
if you make over that you technically do
not qualify
but there's a workaround and that's what
i just said
and it's perfectly moral perfectly legal
so um again i've done one every year
for gosh as long as there's been roth
iras so
just to get more money in there it's not
it's not gonna
that one thing is not gonna make you
wealthy but uh if you keep doing a whole
lot of those one things
you'll end up with more than one thing
that's right every little bit counts and
seriously
go to daveramsey.com you can reach out
to a smart investor pro
where you can sit down you don't have to
try to explain that to your spouse
right just set up the appointment go sit
down with a smart vester pro with your
spouse
with your spouse yes both of you even if
you got to do it on zoom doesn't matter
these guys and gals are fantastic
they'll be able to explain it lay it out
for you and you can feel confident in
what you're doing
there you go jeff is with us jeff's in
knoxville hi jeff welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey dave hey chris appreciate all you
guys do sure you too what's up
well i got a question you're always
giving recommendations for purchasing a
house
uh but i own land outright we're
debt-free
we're saving up to to build a house good
uh
so i was wondering what's your
recommendation do i need to save up the
complete 20
to the cost of the build or is it okay
to actually use the land as
my 20 collateral for the build well
we're not hardcore
on a first home or on the 20 the biggest
thing about the 20
down is it avoids pmi you don't pay the
private mortgage insurance which is like
75 bucks a month per 100
000 and so it's it's a lot of money for
pmi and if you can put the 20
down that's very helpful and yes in the
calculation for your permanent mortgage
the land is part of the valuation
and so if if you are in the property by
the time you get it built with the paid
for land
plus the build if the total loan to
value ratio is 80
or below you've avoided pmi with a
conventional mortgage and a fannie mae
which is the only kind you'd want to do
the other the fha and va are more
expensive and don't do those
but you can avoid the pmi if you do that
and then as far as the other percentage
we use this still applies
when you end up with a permanent
mortgage you don't want it to be more
than a fourth of your income that's
right yeah 15-year fixed 15-year fix and
so you know
jeff here's the deal buddy you're just
going to have to go into it you got to
plan for and dave i'm going to hear this
because you've built more times than me
but you got to plan for overruns you
know like the construction
uh you're the the cost things i mean
it's just it's going to always cost a
little bit more than you plan on
and so having that regularly scheduled
meeting with your builder staying on top
of it
it's it becomes a full-time job well
it's it's a job for sure i don't i mean
i've
you're right and we have learned
building houses
um you are a nightmare to your builder
if you make it up as you go 40 000
change orders right
yes and so the lady a country music star
not to be named
was living across the street from me in
the house i currently live in we were
both building at the same time
and she paid almost double
by the time she finished for the same
square footage as i've got
but i had two change orders and she had
240.
and they mark every change order up and
every every change order means something
has to be changed it's already done
so that means you've done the work twice
right so the first thing you do is you
build
you build it on paper over and over and
over again that's called a blueprint
and you spend a lot of time going over
it and going over it and going over the
blueprint
getting everything just right and and
you know to the point that you're just
it's like a budget you're promising
yourself you're going to stick to that
piece of paper
because everything you change on it as
it goes up is going to be expensive
so it's a lot cheaper to build it on
paper okay and
then you lay out a schedule with the
builder and i don't mean a completion
date
i mean a when the foundation is going to
be poured when the things are going you
know
when the framing package is going in
when the kitchen cabinets are going to
be installed
i want to see dates okay and then we can
tell if we're on schedule or not that's
right if we have a rain delay
some wet weather in the winter in some
of your areas and you know you can tell
we're off by two weeks that we're
building a 200 000 square foot 40
million dollar building next door it's
exactly the same thing we've done
line item on the uh the blueprints are
unbelievably detailed as you might
imagine
and the schedule is unbelievably
detailed and we can tell if we're one
day
off schedule on that project
40 million dollar project and you do
that with the house too and
so you have a budget you have a schedule
and you have a blueprint and the budget
is line itemed as well
all right you go there's so much we've
got set out for kitchen cabinets and if
you pick kitchen cabinets
two thousand dollars over that expect
that to be two thousand dollars more
because you just changed the game that's
right
you know as to what you versus what you
started with and so it's a project
with a lot of details right and if
you'll manage to the budget to the
schedule into the blueprint that's how
you manage the project
and you'll have a good experience and
your builder will actually like you
um but because people just make up crap
as they go along
and then get mad at the building yeah
well you took it
six months longer to build it you
changed 46 things
right you couldn't you didn't go down
and pick out your light fixtures till
four weeks after you were supposed to
and then they didn't come in
right you know and so the the person the
customer
is the problem most of the time or
sometimes a builder's just building
something out of his ear
you know he's everything's on the hood
of the truck and he ain't got any dead
gum
plans you know it's not it's just
horrible and so you've got to
not be jack leg as a customer or as a
builder right but if you'll get a
professional
contractor that knows your stuff and
puts out those three pieces of paper
you spend a lot of time on those before
you break ground you'll have an
enjoyable building a house is fun then
cause you get to
you get the creation i mean we're having
fun building this big old building next
door it's
fun right there's lots of tractors and
trucks and stuff over there
boys i like it man it's fun lots of
things over there making noise it's a
blast there you go
people you just got info on how to build
a house the dave ramsey way it's just
managing a project
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host chris hogan
ramsey personality and number one
best-selling author
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight
two five five two two five
tom is with us to start us off in grand
rapids michigan hey
tom welcome to the dave ramsey show hey
dave hey chris thanks for checking my
call
sure what's up hey so uh my wife and i
are about to
close on our second home um we're about
25
i'm 25 she's 26. we have enough between
cash and investments to pay
for the whole home in cash the problem
is
a lot of it is in investments and
a lot of it about half of it was put in
around
april and so we're looking at paying
potentially short-term or long-term
capital gains in a couple months if we
were to take it out
and we're kind of just like it's gotten
to a large number and
the amount of money that you know i
could be potentially making year over
year
just you know and study growth being in
good mutual funds
i'm worried about taking that large
amount of money
out um and not just continuing to let it
grow and
especially since the mortgage rate is so
low
but tom how much money were you talking
about you're saying a large amount give
us give us some specifics
yeah so i got about 160 000 in cash and
i have about 430
000 investments and what's the basis on
that 430
uh what do you mean what'd you pay for
it uh so i have about
245 000 in actual cash
that was put in no no that's what you
put in to make 400
yeah so you got 200 000 gain in in
nine nine months yep okay
all right and so yeah you're gonna pay
ordinary income on that so that's gonna
be pretty heavy
pretty hefty all right so that that's
question one um
and then the overarching question is uh
do i pay six hundred thousand dollars
for a house and pay cash
because mortgage rates are low yeah i
mean it's it's 535 000 is the home cost
um and so uh you know i i
my thought is is we're both maxing out
our 401ks uh we make just a little over
200
000 a year and you know we could just
divert
you know roughly 60 000 a year
for the next six years or so or you know
after the 20
down six seven years and just do it that
way rather than
you know emptying all of our investments
and stuff and
you know paying cash it's the only debt
we would have right let's let's
let's pan back just a little bit because
there's two or three different
answers uh and it's it's the nuances of
it
okay number one where do we want to end
up 10 years from now let's pound back
that far
a hundred percent of the time all of the
data
that we find i mean is it a hundred
percent of the time you're going to want
to be debt-free
all right 10 years from today okay or
seven years from today or as you said
six years from today all right so the
long-term goal is debt-free now why
is that well it adds stabilization to
your overall life
and and that you own your home there's
no threats when there's a pandemic that
something turns upside down on your
wonderful
careers that you have and all of a
sudden this house is in jeopardy and
everything's in jeopardy and there's a
lot of stress
so if you're the third pig that built
his house on the brick
with the big bad wolf comes along and
the brick is paid for you got no issue
that's right so that's where we want to
end up and we know from all our data
that the millionaires want to do that
and we know the borrower really is slave
to the lender that's not a dad gum joke
and so that's where we want to end up so
in light of that
i figured out i don't borrow money ever
for
anything and so i would be looking at a
delayed
closing on this to get me past the
capital gains date
so i wouldn't close on this property
until april and i'd actually pay them a
little extra to do that if it's me
because i'm going to pay 100
cash 100 of the time now the one thing
we don't yell at people
for is taking out a mortgage if they can
pay it off rather quickly
uh or as quickly as possible and so we
wouldn't yell at you if you took out a
short-term bank loan and paid it off
within a year
to avoid the to make that a long-term
capital gain instead of an ordinary gain
which is going to cut your tax bill in
half
that's a 30 or a 40 000 play in this
scenario
right tax savings only now am i going to
keep you
in debt on your house because of low
mortgage rates
in order to invest more absolutely not
as a philosophy absolutely not so that's
not where i want you to be long-term
it's not where i want you to be as soon
as you can get there
so there's two or three things playing
in this but the capital gains thing
and the april the april date and again
you know you take a
ordinary income on a 200 000 gain or 250
000 gain
versus a 15 uh which is what you'd be on
your
long term capital after one year yeah
i'm probably going to
want you to mess with that i can't
because i have vowed before god i will
never borrow money again
for any reason because i truly believe
the teach stuff we teach
so in if i were in your shoes and i'm
sweating that capital gain i'm gonna
just do a delayed closing in order to
avoid it
and get it past that one year mark and
come out of there but tom
you know you're really kind of asking
two questions the the capital gains
thing and the gains that you've had this
year
right have made you a little greedy
because you had an unrealistically good
year on the stock market
it is unrealistic it was a wonderful
year oh well especially when you bought
at the bottom that's right
absolutely right at the bottom and tom
i'm going to tell you this
25 and 26 years old calling in with this
kind of question
and the path you all are on you've got
the habit of saving you've got the habit
of being intentional
please please please continue to grow
that skill uh do not backslide and i
know that because having been 25 and 26
stupid comes around and it's shiny
and it's real easy if you're not clear
on what it is you want to make some bad
decisions so
very proud of the progress you're making
take your time look at this
and it's okay to delay some
gratification because it's going to feel
a whole lot better later when you walk
in that home and it's
all yours yeah the number of times
i couldn't do something because i didn't
have the money
right then and so because i refuse to
borrow money because i truly believe the
borrower's slave of the lender i really
am a legalist
i really am a fanatic i really don't
borrow money
for anything but the number of times i
couldn't do something so i didn't
because i couldn't figure out a way to
do it i couldn't scheme it i couldn't
scam it
i end up with a better deal like let's
say
he said okay i can't do this if i'm not
going to do a delayed closing
because i'm unwilling to pay the capital
gains and i'm unwilling to borrow money
right okay and so we're gonna and and
then the the seller says no i won't do
it late closing
you lose the deal yeah you know what you
end up with better house later
every time you get an upgrade wow god's
always standing there with an upgrade
the other side of you making the right
decision and that's not what our mind
tells us no
no it's our mind we have a shortage a
scarcity mentality
that if you don't do this you're never
ever going to be able to do it
the number of times i've walked away
with a deal and when i walk around the
corner
there's a better one waiting because i
walked away from the deal for the right
reasons wow there's thinking about
sticking to the principles i'm gonna
dance with the girl that brought me
that's right i mean this debt-free thing
it brought me here
it's real this you know investing thing
it brought me here this outrageous
generosity thing
it brought me here and i'm not going i'm
not gonna i don't care if there's
another pretty girl to party
those are the ones that i came with
that's the girl i came with you know i'm
dancing with her that's it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means that even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they will remake your window
blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey
to get the best possible deal all right
dave today's question comes from crosby
in idaho
he says why do you recommend
only 15 of your household income to be
invested if i can do more
should i ah
so looking at this crosby i would take a
stab at this dave
you you get 15 what you want to do is to
get started and allow compound interest
to start moving for you
however you're still going to be doing
some other things for example we
invested baby step 4 15
you're still going to be saving for
college and you're going to be attacking
to pac
attack and pay off the house now crosby
once you attack and pay off the house
you definitely can invest
more than 15 percent because you freed
up that income
that payment from going to the mortgage
yeah it only applies until the home is
paid for that's right
and once your home is paid off then
you're you've got a lot more cash flow
and you can do other stuff wide open
spaces
so obviously you could do 12 and put
more towards the mortgage
you could do 17 and put less towards the
mortgage
so why 15 is it magical no
right it's not magical it's not a magic
number but
we did when we were designing the baby
steps we learned the baby steps from
working with people
over the years we finally said we first
used to tell people to stop doing
everything get out of debt
then we developed people kept having you
know the tire would blow out the
alternator go out on their car
a kid who gets sickness 200 at the
pediatrician and they have any money
because they paid it all on the debt
right so then baby step one was born
so before you get out of debt have a
thousand dollars so you got a little
starter cushion so i was born
these steps evolved right we didn't just
make them up in a room right
they evolved in 30 years of coaching and
counseling people
so once we got out of debt and got the
emergency fund in place then we said
okay what
what number in the budget with the
average household income is 59 000
in america but if you're making 32 000
the number still works
and if you're making a 232 000 the
number still works
what percentage allows you to have money
left
beyond that percentage that's a big
healthy percentage
right but beyond that you'd have money
left for college savings and beyond that
money left to begin to pay off your home
earlier
and uh we played with 10 percent 12
percent 17
um because we have people that are super
savers and they would put 28
in right and then we have people that go
i only want to put three percent in
because i want to pay off my house
right and we knew neither one of those
were right because you need to have a
good healthy amount going in
but not so much that you don't have any
left to flow
over the edge of the cup over into the
other two baby steps
and so we ran uh case study scenarios
off of real people
that we had met with you know all these
tens of thousands now today hundreds of
thousands of budgets that we have done
at ramsey
and the 15 just works it works at almost
any number
now again this is not out of the bible
right and so it's not an absolute you
can decide to do whatever you want to do
if you want to do 17
do it i wouldn't recommend it this comes
from real experience
we didn't just make these numbers up
there this wasn't in a think tank
somewhere
right that some stupid bro college
professor came up with
you know and you know got tenure and no
money
you know you don't want people with no
money teaching you about money here's
the the
magic of it is obviously most everyone
has picked up on your percentage
that you've devised because it does
allow people to continue to take care of
life
but at the same time get compound growth
started in your favor
and the same thing when we talk about
buying a car you don't have cars that
are more than half your annual income
you pay cash because you have too much
invested in going down in value
right and same thing we talk about no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed on your mortgage
you don't want to be in debt long term
so no more than 15 years and if you have
more than 25 percent
go of your take-home pay going into your
mortgage you're gonna have trouble
saving to buy and pay cash for the next
car you're gonna have trouble paying
cash for your vacations
you're gonna have trouble doing your 15
percent into your retirement and kids
college and been paying the house off
even earlier
right so you become house poor you can
become investment poor
yes you can cash wise and you can become
house poor
cash wise you can become car poor cash
wise
and these are the things that kick
people in the kneecap while they're
trying to get ahead
right well and i remember when i first
started working the plan
and i was like thousand dollars that's
not that's not enough well it's not
enough
and then i realized i was like ah wait a
minute no no no
this is going to break the habit of me
thinking that that's an option
and it's going to give me a little bit
of cushion yeah you know and it was one
of those things where you go
ah because if you won't do that one if
you won't do the thousand
you ain't no way in the world you're
going to do babysitting you'll submit
yourself
to a plan you're not going to submit
yourself to a plan that's right you know
what was happening chris and this is in
the early days of financial peace
university
before there was baby steps i mean i was
i was teaching this stuff and i'm
teaching it in class
and we're sitting in the having small
groups and what would happen is that
somebody would have that was really
earnest
they really had had an i've had it
moment they really were ready to change
they really wanted to get out of debt
and they're really game on and they're
you know they're they're charging the
gates of hell with a water pistol here
we go baby let's get going you know game
on let's bust this thing braveheart this
thing right let's go
and they go down there about three
months and they're busting into this
thing and their emotional
energy is starting to run a little bit
low but they are making progress
and then that alternator would go out or
that that you know
tires you know brakes go out on the car
or something
a kid gets sick some little thing and
you know it really didn't ruin their
plan
the fact that they pulled out an old
credit card and went and bought tires
but it ruined the psychology for them
because they felt dirty
they felt like a drunk that had gone and
got somebody that was
an alcoholic that had been dry for 90
days and then went got drunk
right they felt dirty and so they'd quit
so the thousand dollars isn't about you
and about never using a credit card
again it's about the feeling that
you you went back to the old ways
you know the the proverbs talks about a
dog returning to its vomit
you know it's how it feels you wake up
and you go man
and you just feel like you feel like a
dog you feel awful because you failed
and you really didn't right it's 200
on a credit card guy's got 42 000 on his
credit cards right but
dollars didn't really keep him from
winning that's right
but the fact that he fell off the wagon
did and the thousand that's all the
thousand dollars is for hmm
it has nothing to do with the actual
math right
right it's to keep you from feeling like
you're not working the plan right
gotcha like you failed and that's what's
worked
yeah and that's why that's why it's so
important and so you know you see these
stupid but people posting stuff about us
on the internet and man there's
everything in the world out there
people just make up stuff i mean tom
cruise had sex with an alien you know
i'm sure we interviewed the alien you
know i mean they just
make up crap and so but but they you
know
dave ramsey doesn't understand he you
know he's out of touch with the times a
thousand dollars
well thousand dollars wasn't enough when
we started either tuber right
it was never enough it was never
intended to be enough
and and you know and and you know some
financial planner
dave ramsey thinks a thousand dollars is
an emergency fund no he doesn't you
[ __ ]
that's right i tell you what i think an
emergency fund is three to six months of
expenses
the same thing that's been taught in the
financial planning community for 50
freaking years
right you know it's the same exact thing
the rainy day fund grandma's rainy faint
day fund the
gok fund the god only knows fun it's
always been the same
i didn't make any of this up the only
thing about the thousand dollars is to
keep your emotions intact
and you don't feel dirty like you didn't
work the plan
when some little dinky butt little
emergency comes along now you have a ten
thousand dollar emergency you got
another issue
that's right while you're in baby step
one right yeah you do you got a
different thing going on then
but most people don't have a ten
thousand dollar emergency
but about once every 10 years 78
of americans will face a 10 000
emergency
fund once a decade
now the trick is are you going to be
ready when that comes when it happens
and you will be if you work these baby
steps in order that's right
but during the time you're in baby step
two the number of times
that that big emergency comes along at
exactly the wrong time
it's fairly really rare it doesn't
happen often well
it's more about worrying about the
unknown yeah that's so good to hear the
the the rationale behind that i'm glad
we talked about that that's good
and listen if you're out there and you
fell off the wagon get back
up on that thing this is 2021 you still
got time
just gotten started let's do it this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior
shutters with easy online ordering free
shipping and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
um
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
tyler and shawna are with us in boston
mass
see it says on my screen you guys are
debt free congratulations
we are thank you way to go how much did
you pay off
we have paid off 343
993 in 36 months
wow and your range of income during that
time
so we started around 150 000 and then
uh when we finally paid everything off
we were up to 240.
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
nurse but i'm currently staying home
with
our three kids and and i'm in sales
sounds like it
[Laughter]
yes yeah you guys are taking care of
business so tell me what stuff did you
pay off
so we had quite a bit of student loan
debt about
245 000. uh
yeah yeah our cars uh credit cards and
then a 401k
loan okay so you did over a hundred
thousand dollars average
a year for three years
you've been on beans and rice or you
sold some stuff or you had some savings
you threw it definitely
we definitely sold some stuff i'll let
tyler
tell you about that yeah we sold a
couple things we actually lived in a
three family and rented out the other
two units as part of this
and did a condo conversion and sold them
all individually so that put a good
amount of money in the bank
and you might see pictures of our cars
on the screen
uh one of them is a very excited car a
picture of us
leasing a new car we paid all those off
and then decided we wanted to
dollars in the bank uh you cut out you
said you paid one of them off and last i
heard you were leasing a car so i'm
confused
well we we paid off a lease car so we
had two cars that we financed one was
leased
and we paid them both off and just
decided we didn't need that much car so
we actually
we traded down to a smaller car and put
sixteen thousand dollars towards our
debt
oh wow i actually yeah i actually
totaled that car three months later and
you you hear people call in and use it
as an excuse to buy more car we actually
traded down tried it down again
are you guys there yes we went down
again
okay you're breaking up pretty bad okay
good congratulations
so what's the key to getting out of debt
you did an incredible job
yeah i think the key to getting out of
debt is really having a big why
uh you know for us we accepted jesus
christ as our lord and savior as we
started this process
and decided we had a tithe and and we
just realized we were managing our money
poorly and
needed to change something so i think
that was one of the big reasons that
we decided we needed to make a change
and to just
show our kids that you could do things
differently that
living debt-free was normal yeah
absolutely shanna what was the biggest
sacrifice for you
um i would say just i guess learning to
say
you know know all around whether it be
you know going out shopping or going out
to eat
just learning that word no that wasn't a
word really in our vocabulary and we
quickly had to learn
what it meant what you said you guys
accepted the lord right about the time
you started all this tell us the story
what happened here
yeah about three months probably before
we started our debt-free journey we both
found the lord and accepted him and
decided we had to tithe and we just
looked at our
budget and realized we were going to be
living on 90 less than we had been
before
the numbers didn't work and we weren't
sure how we were going to do that but we
just made the commitment to do it anyway
and
uh you know the the lord's really
blessed our 90 percent
more than our 100 percent ever ever
worked for us in the past
yeah and so a couple months later you
found financial peace university did you
say
yeah somebody at our church was
promoting it on the stage peter and
alicia martino we uh
we actually couldn't take it at the time
and we kind of did dave ish for probably
16 months before we finally did
fpu on our own online uh we're actually
going to be leading our first fpu
course in a few weeks so we're pretty
excited about that wow thank you yeah
that is fantastic
good for you guys we're excited to just
share what we've learned and just
you know the excitement that we felt and
the freedom that we've found
i mean we want everybody to experience
that well i'm going to tell you you guys
calling in and sharing your story you
have no idea
how you're motivating other people to
start to believe that they can
too and so i'm proud of you guys and i'm
very honored that you're going to go
back and pay it forward
uh leading a class and helping other
people find their way as well so
job well done amen well done you guys
so this was a pretty intense three years
yeah yeah it actually went by faster
than
it felt it was going at times you know
when you got when you got done was it
worth it
absolutely will you ever go back in yeah
no way
no not a chance no yeah you live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else
i mean you make 240 000 a year you don't
have any payments but a house payment
uh yeah that's pretty rowdy yeah exactly
yeah we can go do some stuff yeah
that's why we did it we got a copy of uh
chris's book everyday millionaires for
you guys
because you're going to be one soon
that's the next chapter in your story
keep working keep working keep being
intentional
and slow down on the intensity a little
bit but now the intentionality kicks in
so well done you two we're proud of you
thank you for leading financial peace
university and ramsey plus we appreciate
that
tyler and shauna and boston mass 344
thousand dollars paid
off in 36 months making 150 to 240 count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
it's so good is a lot of money a whole
lot
i mean dave that's all 245 000 in
student loan
yeah that's that's a lot of money that's
a whole lot
folks what if you didn't have any
payments what if you didn't have a
credit card or medical bills or student
loans or no car
payments after 2020 most of america
feels the same way you do right now
stressed
out of control but 2021 can be your year
time for you to take control
the best way to do that's the ramsey
plus money
reset it's our challenge for anyone who
starts ramsey plus this year
how much progress can you make on your
money if you go all in
for 90 days all into paying off your
debt as fast as you can and then finally
saving for emergencies as fast as you
can
with ramsey plus we're going to show you
every day what to do
every week what to do the small wins
with your money
and even some really big ones and then
we're going to help you turn those wins
into lifelong habits it is never
too late to get a great start
this year decide to reset your money go
all in for 90 days take control
you can do a free trial at ramsey plus
if you want to it's includes financial
peace university
it includes the every dollar premium app
it includes all kinds of tools and other
courses and classes it's everything you
need to know about money in one
place daveramsey.com
reset do the free trial daveramsey.com
reset yeah no that's important dave and
i've been listening i've been watching
people you know i've been
i've been you know doing a little cardio
and doing some stuff getting getting
myself in better shape but they
i was reading on it it was talking about
you need a system
you need a system and a process to be
able to follow
in order to get healthier and do all the
things i thought that's exactly what
ramsay plus is
it's the system it's the thing you plug
into
and do the things that are there well
one of the best phrases i've ever heard
was
craig rochelle the other night and we
did research last tuesday night and uh a
week ago today
in oklahoma city that went fast and um
you know he he said
quit trying start training yeah
yeah training is you're gonna make
mistakes when you're training and it's
never perfect it's never a straight line
from where you are to being wherever you
wanna be but you when you're in training
you don't eat that when you're in
training you don't buy that that's right
you don't have
training i can't do that i'm in training
that's right
i can't do that i'm in training and all
you just keep saying that
that's a really powerful little phrase
right there
it really is i'm trying to get out of
that nope
i'm in training i can't i can't i can't
i can't do that
amazon prime nope nope i can't click
that nope
nope that big old pop-up ad that comes
looking at you they get up we need to
get like a nope button we do
you and i both when you push it it's
hope when it's chris's voice
no no that's what we're gonna tell
people
this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
caesar is with us in fort myers florida
hey cesar how are you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
oh thank you so much for the call what
an honor
really for you too for me to talk to you
guys um so
i sold my house i used to live in
connecticut moved to florida about
a month and a half ago i sold a house in
connecticut for 225 000
and i owe 20 uh 210
000 here in fort myers in my second home
um not sure if i should use to
invest the 225 or pay off uh
my home right now my house hmm how much
do you uh you owe 210 on the current
house
correct you just took 35. okay so you
took out a mortgage
on it and the money from the home sale
in connecticut was just sitting in the
bank
it is sitting in the bank right now he
had the mortgage earlier oh okay
but now you can pay it off i could yeah
yes uh well caesar
yeah what are you hesitating about bud
what's wrong because uh i i retire about
uh probably uh back in april eight
months ago
i'm 48 years so 48 years old uh
i have an 80 000 pension coming in okay
and i have about
ten 410 on the 457. there you go uh
right now right and i
i could continue making mortgage
payments on my
with my retirement um
so let's try it this way let's pretend
for a second
that you did not have any of this 200
000 left
and you had a paid-for house that you're
living in there in fort myers in other
words you paid off the house okay
so pretend you're sitting there in a
paid for house with that money in the
457 and the 80 000 pension
and you're sitting there in a home in
fort myers and that home is worth what
335 right now okay if you were sitting
there in a paid for house
with your 457 and with your pension and
no other monies other than
what you know not not counting the money
from connecticut right
would you go get a new mortgage on the
fort myer house
in order to invest
no same thing
thank you
[Laughter]
let me tell you what that little trick
does okay yeah here's what's going on
when someone asks including me because
i'm a math nerd
should i pay off my home because
mortgage rates are low and i can make
more by investing it into a mutual fund
you are using your brain to do math
and you're considering with good
critical thinking skills does the math
work to do this
right now when i reverse and i do that
little trick
which is a you know it's called a sunk
cost analysis in other words do we
reverse engineering something's all
we're doing right when i do that
it causes you to think not just with
your brain but also with your heart
because your brain didn't leap when i
suggested you go get a new mortgage
your stomach did into your heart
right and so that's where you measure
risk is
is in your heart you measure you do math
in your head
yeah and you have to use both to have a
good financial plan
and too many people in the financial
world only use
the brain for the math and they don't
use the risk analysis
of the heart that's good math is in the
head risk is in the heart
i mean that's uh you know you think
about your physical reaction
that's right when you think about going
and getting a mortgage on a paid for
house you go you kind of
no it kind of like yeah like i feel like
you got the hiccups
got tight yeah no your diaphragm your
abdomen changed your brain didn't move
at all no
it didn't even flinch not at all that's
amazing
you're gonna you're gonna be feeling so
different yeah paying off really are
buddy you're gonna feel so
done a great job and thank you for being
a listener 48 years old and retired
yes he's done it the right way
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five mike
is in boise idaho hey mike how are you
hey guys how you doing today better than
i deserve what's up
uh thank you for taking my call i'm
hoping you guys can help
maybe settle a discussion my wife and i
are having on the last item in our
snowball
i we i bought a
2014 ford raptor shelby
about six months ago so we and um
yeah yeah to uh to fix up and actually
flip
that was the intent um we got a pretty
good deal
well okay so my wife actually fell in
love
with a wrap this is funny with the
raptor
i love it she uh i love this one got a
little bit of a
show she's got a little bit of anxiety
while driving and
for whatever reason when we get in this
truck and drive on the freeway
and visit our relatives she doesn't have
anxiety driving
i drive one every day i love her she's
safe
so she loves it so so where we're at
right now is we paid
everything off with that and what do
y'all want you know i
what's that what do you owe on it oh
30 about 30 000. what's your household
income
175. okay and then what's your question
so my question is we're deciding on
whether or not to sell it right now
yeah i purchased it with the idea to
flip it it's worth about 45 to 50
depending on the buyer right now
because it's kind of that special
supercharged package the whole thing
my concern with selling is we haven't
got very far
in retirement i'm 43 and
we were thinking hey if we sell this
we're done we'll put a little cash in
our pocket
um but you know we enjoy driving it so
much it makes the traveling so nice
she's down on the fence where she's like
what's your other car
what's your other car worth what uh
let's see she's got a 2014 escape and
it's like maybe 15 grand and that's the
only other you only have two cars
no no sorry so so when i talk to the gal
so i've got a couple of especially
vehicles and that's one of the reasons
that
i'm kind of leaning towards selling i've
got a couple early broncos
as well that i've had for years man
um you have a good time and so i fixed
them up restored them and and they're in
the garage so
how much are they important mike how
much are the broncos yeah they're worth
100 grand
yeah so the one i have is an all
original uncut
one it's probably worth in the 60 000
neighborhood and then the
one that's more of a tourist probably
worth mid 40s i would say
okay you got a lot tied up in cars now
those two cars there i'm going to pull
them to the side
because they're probably not going down
in value they're specialty vehicles
they're collectibles
but 90 percent of the time 98 of time
you buy something with wheels or motors
it's going down in value
and you just don't want to have too much
tied up in toys you guys got a lot in
toys
we we do and that's kind of where we're
both trying to have the description
for you to the broncos say that one more
time please how emotionally tied are you
to the broncos
um one of them i'm pretty emotionally
tied to just because of what it is i
mean the other one is so i mean i
am i'm emotionally tied to them they're
so rare i can never replace them no
that's true
i love how honest you are mike i like
how you're trying so it might be
i mean i i was just thinking because i'm
a car guy and i'm into all
all these cars you're talking about i
love every one of them these are you got
some sweet stuff there
you got good taste i i'm probably
dropping a bronco and keeping the raptor
but that's just
me that's just me
yeah i don't care what you do i'm a
little bit afraid with all four of them
you've got an awful lot tied up in
rolling stock with 170 000
income okay yeah you're gonna get that
you're gonna get the 30 paid off and
you're going to retire a millionaire i'm
not
worried about that i just want you you
got to stop buying cars i know that yeah
well especially ones you keep that's
right because you know
mike you're only a few months away from
finding another one
i'm with you i'm with you dave pick a
bronco
sacrifice i pay off the raptor put mama
in that put mama in that raptor
you think he's going to drive the escape
no chance
there's wait a minute no change sell the
escape
that's what i'm saying that's true yeah
get rid of that thing and then drop
the only thing on this list that i don't
care about yeah
get rid of that thing sorry escape this
is a boy discussion right here i'm just
saying
oh i don't know man that's a hard one
that is tough
just you don't want too much tied up in
rolling stock get rid of the debt if
you're going to keep it for sure you
don't want to keep the debt around
and i don't blame you for having this
discussion oh this is a good one this is
a good one
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five chris
hogan ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host you jump in
we'll talk to you about your life and
your money as promised
crystal's with us in philadelphia hi
crystal welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you for taking my question sure
what's up
i am calling because i recently
inherited
an annuity and i am not sure
if i should just go ahead and pay off my
home
or if i should go ahead and roll it over
and invest it
how much is it um it is 139
000. what do you owe in your home i owe
119 000
and if you've gotten a tax person look
at it and see how much you'll be taxed
when you cash this out
um i actually just contacted one
of your recommendations and i was faced
with them today but
um they had to reschedule the time for
tomorrow i also had
spoken to three of your smart investor
pros which i all liked
so i haven't picked one yet um
good i'm glad i'm glad it's hard to
choose uh so the
you were named beneficiary on the
annuity yes it was divided
uh three ways between me and my brothers
hmm crystal who left this to you
my father your father i think uh
with you being named a beneficiary it's
probably going to be more like life
insurance than it is going to be like an
inherited ira
i don't think you're going to have taxes
on it but i'm not sure
i'm not sure i think i think as because
you're named the beneficiary on i think
it's just going to come straight to you
i'm not very good at taxes though
so the tax people are all out there
listening right now going oh god
you know but um anyway because so for
sure check me out so
i promise okay so uh
i'm paying off my house unless i've got
a 40
tax on this thing if it's got a big tax
on it of some kind and you can roll it
to something
which i don't think you can do i know
you can't roll it into an ira you could
roll it into a variable annuity
i i'm going to say nine times out of ten
and unless you get just some
ridiculously horrible information about
the taxes
i am going to take it out even if i got
a little bit of tax and pay it off
pay off the house okay yeah okay crystal
how much is your mortgage payment right
now
uh mortgage and taxes is roughly
13 50. can you imagine
what kind of blessing it is for your
father to have left that to you
to pay off your home like you get the
deed you own it
and now you have thirteen hundred and
fifty dollars extra in your budget
i just had a happy feeling in my heart
because this is this has been a rough
thing
because my dad was handicapped um 22
years ago
and i took care of him for 15 years my
brother just took care of him for
the last seven we had a family member
that was his
power of attorney yes ma'am and never
invested his annuity
and so realizing the amount of money
that it could have been
right um what i was actually expecting
was a little
shocking about seven years ago when um
that person passed away and he went to
live with
uh another family member a brother
who was his power of attorney and he
didn't invest the money either so this
money grew for 22 years at one percent
interest so um that hurts a bit
yeah yeah but now we're still here
and the good news is your home's going
to be paid off that's right and when you
get ready to leave something to someone
that home will have appreciated and
it'll be it'll make a difference
so at any rate you know this is one of
those things let that go
uh just realize your father thought of
you and was intentional enough to leave
something to you
and you get a chance to write continue
writing the story together
ben is with us in knoxville hey ben
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi i appreciate you all taking my call
sure how can we help
um so uh i am engaged and i'll be uh
getting married here in april yay
thank you we're both very excited and uh
fortunately we're both going into the
marriage on baby step six
and our combined income will be about
two hundred thousand and
um i was wondering how you would suggest
um
kind of managing our individual um wants
within our marriage for example i'm i'm
a big gun guy and so that's my hobby and
uh
my fiance likes you know clothes and
furniture and stuff like that
well the good news is you don't have any
debt except your house
and you've got a lot of money to buy
guns and clothes
so i mean you called me up with this
problem making
i mean with 300 000 in student loan debt
because i would have said no more guns
and you know very few clothes
so but yeah i mean the good news is you
can sit down together and i
i i will just tell you uh every gun i
buy
cost me at least two purses
[Laughter]
so there we have a we have a formula at
the ramsey house
i'm with you i got a lot of guns and you
know what that means she's got a lot of
purses so
um you know you're just gonna do some of
that right there
and all kidding aside and i think you
just talk about it and
you know it would not be fair for you to
spend you know uh
three times more than she's spending on
those things but
both of you have some fun money category
room in this budget you described yeah
and ben is this a first marriage for
both of you
yes okay that's fantastic man i'm gonna
tell you this have you all done the
pre-marriage counseling
uh we're starting that next okay that's
imperative uh and really dig
into that uh get on the same page
because financially it sounds like you
guys are in sync
now it's a matter of as i tell people
all the time you got to speak french
right it's not you her and you as we and
so
that mindset of the muscles you all have
already been flexing
learning to communicate and flex those
together your biggest problem is
is that you're both used to having your
own life
and you're now going to combine lives
and that's going to require some that's
going to be a little bit stressful yeah
a lot of regards
yeah we'll hear about here what we're
going to do is we're going to put you
into ramsey plus
and that hooks you up with the every
dollar budget and put you guys through
financial peace university as part of
your pre-marriage counseling we're gonna
give you a wedding gift
yes so you hold on and we'll give you a
year in ramsey plus and kelly will pick
up and do that
now what you'll do is jump on that every
dollar budget
and lay out a pretend budget as if you
were married that's good
and then it'll give you something to
talk about in the pre-marriage
counseling
you're going to go ahead and have some
budget fights right now yeah
but but
again the communication on it being able
to lay it out looking at the ratios you
have a common goal baby step six and
paying the house off too
that's right so there's only three
things you can do with money you can
spend it
to enjoy it yep you can give it
and you can invest it and you need to be
on the same page
on how much is going to what and there
should be plenty of room to do all three
of those things with what you have
described here you guys are making a lot
of money you're doing really well
congratulations seriously that's going
to be good but yeah
they they you all have uh a streak of
uh independence because you've
lived as grown-ups with a lot of money
before now you're going to have to
combine that and that's going to be
emotionally
there's going to be some friction with
that it goes with the territory
put it all out on the table work the
friction work the friction
it's going to be great for your
communication in your new marriage
awesome put the lord first
and in the center and now the other
stuff will work out just fine
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five if you feel like you've
never saved enough money or pay off all
your debt after a year like 2020 most of
america feels the same way we're all
hitting reset
ramsey plus is our step-by-step plan
helps you get some really quick wins
we're going to give you a 90-day plan
day by day week by week step by step
everything's in there and ramsey plus
of course includes financial peace
university and you can do a free trial
and see if you want to do the whole year
the 90-day plan will get you effect it's
never too late to get a great start
that's right
get a fast start get a great start come
out of it i mean when you come out
of the gate fast boom here we go all
right ramsay plus you try it for free
do the free trial and see if it works
for you you're going to be blown away
daveramsey.com reset daveramsey.com
all you have to lose is some debt
[Laughter]
crystal's in anchorage hey crystal how
are you
hi good thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um currently my husband and i are have
no debt except for
a little bit of a car payment and our
mortgage
we've got a steady income but we kind of
struggle
just getting by check to check and
wondering what is the best way to
kind of get out of that rut what's your
income
oh about six
about 72 000 a year okay how much house
payment
1700. how much car payment
um about i do about 300
a month on it you would do what's your
car
payment you have a payment amount yeah
i i do about 300 a month on it i
i go a little bit extra okay but i mean
your car payment is actually if you
don't do
what's the actual payment 210. okay
that's what i'm asking
all right good okay so that's okay
because you're
the extras of choice you know and that's
not a bad choice because we're gonna get
your
car paid off that's gonna be something
we're gonna do here in a minute but but
uh we're gonna put a lot more than 300
on it but um anyway all right
so you're not giving me any numbers here
that are causing my brain to explode
like you've got major problems which
means
that you're probably like most people
including me
when i first started this uh in that
by not having really good organization
with my money and every detail out laid
out
it the the chaos eats these dollars for
breakfast
and so a written budget a detailed
budget
will make you feel like you've gotten a
raise because i'll give you an example
if you what how often you guys get paid
twice a month
yeah okay so a take-home pay check is
how much
three thousand dollars okay so we got
six thousand dollars
minus house payment minus car payment is
three is that that's two thousand
dollars yeah yeah so i got four
thousand dollars left
because that feels kind of weird doesn't
it it does
like right this second you're asking
yourself i know i got water and
i know i got i got to buy i know i've
got electricity and i know i've got food
uh and i know i got some insurance i got
to buy here and there uh but you're
starting to ask yourself where the flips
is money going and that's
kind of what i'm asking yeah so yeah you
got to get on a game plan and when you
get on a budget you are going to feel
like you got a raise
and crystal i'm going to tell you as i
started off on dave's plan uh
some almost 16 years ago that is exactly
what
was the thing that was the awakening for
me i was doing too much stupid in
grocery stores and in restaurants and
so getting down to the root of it you
taking a look get some bank statements
out
go back and look at the last three
months and find out that category where
you're bleeding money
and it could be online shopping it could
be grocery stores it could be eating out
whatever it is you're going to do an
analysis you're going to see it but you
cannot manage money with a rear view
mirror right
you can't wait till it's over and then
go wow that doesn't work
you have to tell it what to do before it
leaves
on paper on purpose before the month
begins
every single month and in agreement with
your spouse so they don't do something
else
that's exactly right and i was just
going to say with that when you find
that trouble spot
go to the cash envelopes on it i'm
telling you
having the budget like dave's talking
about beforehand and then having the
cash
i'm telling it's going to give you more
control and like dave said it's going to
feel like you gave yourself a raise
because guess what you did yeah jump on
every dollar
and start using the it's free to use
just everydollar.com download the app
and start using that budgeting app with
you and your husband
and you guys start working on that
tonight you're going to feel like you
got a raise
there's a reason you're leaving losing
you know
there's just no intentionality behind
the dollars and no one does by the way
you're not like you're not like horrible
i got a greek nobody does that all right
you have sat down with people for many
many years what is the typical the area
of the budget that people are
absolutely lying about what is it the
one where you go this isn't real
eating out eating out yeah i would agree
i'd say eating out of the grocery store
because with the stores we have nowadays
they spend less at the grocery store
they know they spend it a lot at
restaurants but when they find out what
they really spend they go oh my god yep
yeah
yeah i remember i was sitting in a
financial peace group leading small
group one time years and years ago
and uh you know we're kind of going
around talking about the lesson that
night and we're like okay why aren't why
have you not been able to fund
retirement where it was an investment
lesson
one of the questions we're just talking
about you know why why didn't you feel
like you've been able to do retirement
and there's an old country boy sitting
in the thing and he goes
yeah we looked at it spending 1200
a month in restaurants i know where our
retirement's been going we've been
eating it
about died laughing because he's telling
the truth i've been eating it
that's it that i'm telling you that's
what a lot of people do with it
they eat they eat their future yeah
and that's scary and you know what
that's something we can control
because what couldn't we just tell you i
love restaurants
yeah a lot of my i've got good friends
you and i have good friends personal
friends
they're world-class chefs that own
restaurants we go to their place
i love that kind of stuff i'm not
against restaurants but from a budgeting
standpoint when you're calling me and
saying i'm broke i have no money
i will tell you that 90 of what you
spend in the restaurant
the money is spent on entertainment 10
is your actual food cost yeah so go home
and make make some make some mix make
some white beans and cornbread well
and and i'm gonna tell you this even
throughout all this situation with the
pandemic
of people being at home more you know
utilizing that
found out what they were spending they
really did because people were like
we've got a lot of all this money where
this money come from that's right and
it's all it was you're not going all the
time
all the time so be intentional be smart
and and again
starting to set some things cut it back
a little bit crystal you're not
different in that regard i don't know if
it's food that you're spending it on but
you will discover it
when you go back and look at the
statements like chris suggested and when
you start writing it down and try to
make it behave
hint for everyone is starting their new
budget this month
whatever you think you're spending at
the grocery store
you're wrong it's more than that
i agree and so if you think you're
spending 500
you better put 750 in there because
you're gonna find
that it's more you've you've been lying
to yourself so long
that you know i really do do that i've
had these people tell me these
ridiculous numbers we make it on fifty
dollars a month no you don't
you can't even no this is absolutely
ridiculous so
you know but but because here's the
thing that is a category that if you
under fund it you will go back and
either break your budget
or you'll have to go back and correct
your budget in the middle of the month
as you're learning how to budget your
first couple of months
if you'll go ahead and over fund it you
don't feel like you failed
you can always cut your food budget back
in future months that's a good call
for the first two to three months you're
doing your budget when you've never done
one in years
over fund your grocery store
budget because your category because
you're always
everyone spends more than they think
they're going what they do
and you people that are super nerds and
you do the coupons and you've got
all these apps on your phone and all
this stuff you still
spend more than you think you have
because we there's something about
denial at the grocery store that we
didn't we're in denial about what we
spent no that's a good point and at the
reset event if you haven't watched that
you need to go check it out
i gave three tips which is make a
grocery list
only buy what's on the list and stick to
the dollar amount you said you were
going to spend i'll give you a fourth
one don't go grocery shopping when
you're hungry
truth big truth as
if i have ever done anything else but
there you go those burritos i bought
from sam's weren't that good when i got
them home well you bought two
270 i know i was hungry dave i was real
hungry
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 elizabeth is in
tyler texas hi elizabeth welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi how are you doing today better than i
deserve what's up
um i have been asked to take over doing
uh being the treasurer for my property
owners association
and are you there yes ma'am
i'm sorry um and um okay sorry um so
anyway so i've been asking you that and
i am curious
about personal liability if i should be
concerned in any way
in regards to that you would need to ask
an attorney i'm not one i do
own many many many pieces of real estate
in hoas and most of them are
a hot mess
[Laughter]
and so there's always conflict and drama
and gossip and stupidity and everything
else
you would as i understand the law and
again
i'm not a lawyer so you're you're you
know it's a legal advised question that
you're really asking but as i understand
the law
you would not have any liability unless
there was misbehavior now obviously if
you
uh bought yourself a a new grill for
your backyard
out of that money then you would
obviously be liable for the misbehavior
or if there was
gross uh negligence you did a horrible
job
beyond the pale of what any
kindergartner could do
then you might be held liable most of
the
hoas carry errors in emissions insurance
for their board of directors and so if a
resident files suit against them for
you know mismanagement or negligence or
fraud or whatever else the eno
will step up the insurance company will
step up and defend them legally
so most of the time you're covered and
even if you're not
you mean you might have be out some
legal fees but you would not be
held to uh if somebody didn't like the
color of paint that was chosen for the
front fence
right which will happen yes um the then
the uh uh then you're not
liable for that yeah elizabeth dave's
not allowed to be on any kind of
committee like that
people people people would end up crying
okay i'm just gonna tell you uh but i i
think
you know do you have a lot of time do
you want to do this or do people just
want you to do it
well it's so it's an interesting
situation i live in a neighborhood where
i have an hoa
and a poa and okay properties understand
you said the poa
it's just for my street okay uh
because there's certain expenses that we
are responsible for just on our street
yes ma'am and so this is for the poa um
and so i would i'm not so sure that we
have errors and admissions on that
because it's such a small thing
yeah well it would have to be the people
on your street
or the hoa that you pay money to out of
the poa
someone would have to get pissed off and
sue you yeah from a practical standpoint
before you would have any liability so
as long as everything's fairly low
drama you probably don't have any issue
but i can't make that promise in an hoa
as you can tell i can't stand the things
and no no reflection on you miss
lizardman you sound like a sweet person
he's a sweetheart you can tell but too
many of the people involved in them
really don't have
a life and so uh would you tell me dave
what's the percent of people that need
to be incarcerated
uh is it two percent or has it grown two
no i'm not incarcerated um
oh and institutionalization same thing
yeah well
sort of ish yeah
and it's it's a higher percentage than
h.o.a but yeah
oh yeah no i'm not i'm just not a fan i
i i'm a yeah okay just let that
yeah here we go kelly kelly kelly's in
atlanta hi kelly how are you
hi good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh thank you for taking my call it's
such a blessing i have a question
about uh our my
okay so i'm a stay-at-home mom and
married my husband makes about 60k a
year
as an essential worker uh his career has
the potential to grow his salary to
about
70k within the next five years
we have two children under three and
i currently have an as in an essential
field with the potential to get a bs in
engineering after
we complete our baby step number three
uh that would be no longer than two
years from now
we are currently paying off our house
and that's the only debt that we have
which is about 155k left to pay off
uh he's mid-20s i'm early 30s and we're
wondering out of
these three options which might be more
advantageous for us
financially speaking the first option
would be if i go back to school
and i get a bs in engineering in less
than five years
to jump start a career with a higher
salary
while maintaining our lifestyle at only
60 to 70k a year
with extra towards other baby steps
the next option would be should we
maintain his salary
and career and the lifestyle that we
have now or the third option would be
would it be better to go back to work
part-time and
try adding on to his salary um the
reason for
us changing head-up households would be
because we feel like
uh one parent uh should be at home with
the kids
but um you know there's always the
the um like the possibility of
us just you know adding on to his salary
and
we could both be at home at the same
time
yeah well i mean there's two or three
things going on it's not just math if
it's just math the answer is how do you
make the most money
yes sir and then you've got to say okay
but what's the uh
what's the trade-off on the way that
makes the most
money what what and you know where do
you what do you want to be doing
career-wise
as well as wealth building wise as well
as parenting
five years from now 10 years from now
and which of these decisions takes you
to that person
and so um so we call it around here when
we're setting business goals strictly
when we're doing strategic analysis in
the business we say what's the desired
future yeah where do you want to be in
10 years
and then what must be true that's not
true today
for us to arrive at that desired future
and in your case it could it be a degree
could it be a change out uh in your
husband who's at home who's not could it
be a different way to do
engineering could it be i don't know i
mean what has to be true
for you to hit your parenting goals your
career goals
and your uh uh relationship
and wealth building your wealth building
goals yeah the closest
and those things need to be but all
three laid out there at the end
and then you start backing out of it and
reverse engineer it and say okay what
must be true
that's not true now and you're kind of
saying that because you're saying i got
to go back get a degree if i'm going to
go this way
i need to go get the bs if i'm going to
do this instead of just the instead of
just the associates right
and um what must be true if we want a
parent at home well he might quit if you
go make more money
and come home and be at a stay home dad
that's right what must be true these are
things that must be true
with the different options but then if
you do those things or you look back and
say
the trade-offs because there always is
yes there is we're the right ones
yes yeah no you're right and and kelly
you all deciding and talking about that
so you can put the priorities and your
husband may have a different level of
priorities but what i want you all to do
is to have the time to communicate
and then hear listen with your heart
it's so easy to listen with your ears
and your head but when you listen with
the heart what you're doing is
you're really hearing and feeling and
understanding the person
and if your husband can feel that you're
doing that for him and he's doing that
for you
you all will look through the lens for
these kids and say hey
what's the what's the route what do we
do and like i agree with you
it's always give and take uh we want the
take take
uh but we got to do the gift well i
think too i mean
you know i'll give an example i had a
young lady the other day that um
was telling us that she had always
wanted to be a nurse
and so coleman ken coleman and his show
suggested she go
and shadow nursing for a couple days
and she went to the hospital and worked
you know beside a nurse and i went
ooh i don't want to do this ah
but nursing is a good career right and
it's good money
it is and you can always get work and
that was what was appealing
but then the actual doing of the job so
you like it yeah do you want to
do engineering 40 hours a week
10 years from today with your bs is that
what you want to do
nothing wrong with that but you need to
be sure that's that's a lot of go
a lot of stuff given up to get there
sure better be sure that's the ladder's
ring
leaning on the wrong building this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our our scripture of the day is proverbs
4 23 keep your heart with all vigilance
for from it flow the springs of life
michael alter says the bad news is time
flies the good news is you're the pilot
that's pretty good colby's with us in
brunswick georgia hi colby welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi thanks for uh having me sure what's
up so
um i'm 18 years old i'm a freshman in
college and i'm trying to figure out
what i should do with the majority of my
income
i make about twenty thousand dollars
between my part-time job
and side hustles um so i'm trying to
figure out
if i should continue investing it the
way i am or should i just
leave it in a savings account for when i
graduate college
and if i need the money it's there what
are you investing it in
uh just in the stock market so uh i have
about eight thousand dollars in
mutual funds and individual stocks and
then
uh last year i put 5000 in a roth ira
good for you well done well done
well colby the best rate of return
on your money is colby
what are you studying aviation science
and flight management
okay so you're going to make more money
as a result of having spent money on
education
than you will make in mutual funds given
that you are studying something that is
actually usable
you're not getting a degree in medieval
left-handed poetry
okay right so um
very wise on your part so the point is
is that the
main use of money for you the number one
job one for money for you is graduate
and
graduate on time and graduate debt-free
so i don't care if you save for
retirement
i do care if you graduate until you
graduate
i do care that you graduate you graduate
on time
and you pay cash and you don't go in
debt now you're a working dude and
you're a saving dude and you're
way ahead of the curve i'm so impressed
with you yeah
kobe you really and truly are buddy um
who taught you about this
did your parents teach you are you
self-taught
yeah my um parents always taught me the
importance of
being wise with your finances and
especially my grandfather
i'm fortunate enough to have my college
paid for
so i'm not having to take out any
student loans or need that so i'll
graduate
college debt free so that's fantastic so
i would ask you to take it a step
further
i want you to find someone that is doing
a pilot or someone private or
or someone that does commercial but
really find out what's the next level
for flight school what's it gonna cost
what are the areas you're thinking of
so that way you can start to save toward
it as well
uh you are way ahead of the game young
man i know mutual funds are fine
single stocks are not good growth stock
mutual funds or just a savings account
knowing that you just don't need to be
fancy just pile up cash a big old pile
of cash when you graduate
means you're a genius yep yep
okay and then you can make all kinds of
choices for
long-term investments buying a home
moving to a new city
do all kinds of stuff when cash gives
you options yeah and you know what dave
i keep getting on my show the chris
hogan show
i'm getting people calling in that are
22 and 23
and they're they're paying cash for
homes they're they've got a hundred
thousand
saved for retirement i'm like who taught
you i've had five of them tell me they
went through foundations
they plugged into our high school
curriculum took it as a freshman
listened to it got out and started doing
it wow
so it is one of those things where you
know in that department it is making a
difference
maria is in tampa hi maria welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call i
appreciate everything you guys have done
thank you my question is yeah can
we afford to build a 589
000 home what will your payments be
right
it should be if we put 20
down it'll be 33-19 okay
and that is that a 15-year fixed
uh no that's a 30-year okay need to
calculate it on a 15-year
and it shouldn't be more than one-fourth
of your take-home pay
and so are you making sixteen thousand
dollars a month take home
no we're making thirteen thousand
dollars take home
okay yeah you're getting ready to sign
up for too much house
yep okay okay and maria
listen to me maria i'm so proud of you
for calling in because the bank or the
mortgage company will allow you to do
that
they will allow you to sign up for that
headache and heartache trip
you have to be aware you and your
husband enough to say uh uh
and you downgrade you you i'm serious
because they will allow it and and what
you'll think is well if they said i can
it must make sense
no it doesn't it makes sense for them
yeah a fourth of your take-home pay on a
15-year fix now take-home pay is not
after 401k
take-home pay is not after insurance
take home pays just
after taxes so what do you get home with
with not counting your investments not
counting
uh health insurance coming out or
anything else that comes out your check
except taxes so all i'm saying about
take home pay is taxes so
if there's a bunch coming out to get to
13 and really if you add back in the
401k and you add back in the health
insurance and it comes out to be
15 then you know we're probably getting
pretty close here because your payment's
going to be on a 15 year or fourth
of your take-home pay and you're going
to be fine so it's not an absolute but
you need to dig into it a little bit
more
and the goal would be one fourth or so
give or take but you just if you get
if you get up where you got 35 of your
take-home pay on a 15 years all you ever
want to do because you want to get the
house paid off that's a big part of
wealth building that's right
and if you get up there at 35 you can't
do other stuff that you need to do
you you get handcuffed dave and i've
spent time in la and in new york and
i've seen people that are home poor
it means they bought so much house that
they can't really live in other places
so
don't necessarily seek to buy the home
you want buy the home that you can
afford
that makes sense for you and your budget
yeah sean is in houston texas hi sean
how are you
hello um i'm doing pretty good i'm
calling because
we're being sued by american express we
were served this weekend the papers we
owe them
we owe them 85 000 we have 50 000
and i'm trying to find out uh do i need
to hire an attorney or should i try to
settle with them for the 50 000 or
i have talked to an attorney they told
me it would be 5100 to hire them
and i'm just trying to find out which
way to go okay uh
that sounds a little steep to settle
that and uh
how far behind are you we left we were
paying uh we we we last paid them in
july uh right after you know the cover
thing uh we were on the world and 85
000 on an amex card it's a
it was a business card and my husband
decided to do a business deal
and fronted all the material for a
project
and that's this yep so here we go
this is why we don't do it okay i just
wanted to learn i wanted to learn the
lesson with you there
ouch i'm sorry i'm sorry you're facing
this yeah
that's a big enough deal i'm not going
to have you settle that on your own i
would get legal representation i don't
think you found the right legal
representation yet
and no you're not bankrupt you have
enough money to settle this amex will do
this
but they are they're skunks they are not
good people
and we deal with them all the time and
you can tell they're lying if their
mouths moving
so you really do need to get legal
representation i think you can settle it
for 50 or less
with them if you haven't paid them since
july try this go to collectionbully.com
collection relief.com that's a group of
attorneys that we recommend for people
that are being bullied by collectors
okay and i think one of them will
probably pick up your case and represent
you for less than that i might be wrong
it might be that much but okay
um okay but if you can settle 85 for 50
and cost you five grand that's still a
deal right
that's still a deal yeah it is and sean
i'm proud of you for being proactive
uh because a lot of people would freeze
in the moment and
uh i'm glad you're being proactive and
acknowledging this for what it is
it is something that needs to be dealt
with absolutely
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
and you're not bankrupt okay so
i'm picking on her her husband but um
38 of small businesses use credit cards
to finance their business ideas
and this is where you end up on the
verge of bankruptcy
stop that crap yeah wow organically grow
your business with the cash that the
business creates
and if you can't if you don't have the
money or can't get a big enough deposit
to cover
the project don't take the price don't
do it
that puts this hour today ramsey showing
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to
walk daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you